this movie stars Johnny Depp or as I
call him the master of white facepaint
[Music]
and I'm gonna stop now
The Lone Ranger is directed by Gore
Verbinski and stars Armie Hammer as the
title character and Johnny Depp as Tonto
this movie attempts to tell a more
realistic tale of how these guys came
together of how a lawman may put on a
mask to do his justice when he doesn't
actually believe in guns in the first
place and how a Native American named
Tonto can be played by Johnny Depp even
though he's not really Native American
but you know what I don't really care
cuz apparently he might have a little
Native American in him I did some
research about of it doesn't really
matter I don't really think it matters
it doesn't really matter it matters a
little bit I guess I just don't really
care and the Lone Ranger and Tonto are
out to foil this giant plan that
involves silver and pillaging and all
different types of evil but the movie is
told from the perspective of old Tonto
is telling a story to a child and then
we get to see the entire film play out
as he's telling this story and very
early on in the movie you get the sense
that this movie isn't really going to
make a lot of sense because it doesn't
horses that appear out of nowhere the
Lone Ranger waking up on some giant
wooden platform how did he get up there
how did he get down later it's never
explained horses running on top of
trains people jumping like a hundred
feet down landing on flat-out rock and
living you know just all different types
of weird things are in this movie that
take you out of the experience but that
isn't really my main issue with the
movie it's more just a constant
annoyance where I kept getting sucked
out of each scene by these weird
cartoony events my main problem with
this movie is it's two-and-a-half hours
long and it just does not need to be
this movie could have been a half an
hour maybe even 40 minutes shorter than
it was this movie has like three
different finales at least it's felt
that way and I kept thinking okay it's
over now oh no there's another gigantic
set piece Oh actually there's another
gigantic set piece and I love me some
set pieces if they're well made and this
film looks good at Gore Verbinski direct
Sun I slicking movie but it just keeps
going on and it keeps going on after a
while the action gets so monotonous and
I said very cartoony that it just
becomes this big bloated thing on top of
that another issue I had with the movie
was as I said this is told from the
perspective of old Tonto telling this
story to a young child yet we
continuously see events that Tonto was
not present for Tonto did not witness
how is he able to retell these events to
a kid when he wasn't there where are all
these scenes coming from how is he able
to retell them to this child he's a
magical ghost I guess and in some ways
the film does depict him as that it's
silly it doesn't make any sense
I think army hammer is a good actor if
he's given the right role and I really
don't think this is the right role for
him he just didn't feel right in this
role and I don't really entirely think
it was his fault I think it was really
the idiotic script and the strange tone
the film has I just think it was like
Gore Verbinski was trying to recreate
the success that he had on the first
Pirates of the Caribbean film which is
what he's already tried to do with
Pirates 2 & 3 and by most people's eyes
didn't really succeed and it feels like
he's trying to do it again he's trying
to create this big gigantic adventure
that's funny and interesting and a good
time but also have a lot of serious
elements in there and it just and Johnny
Depp although playing a very similar
role to Jack Sparrow and really very
similar to a lot of things he's been
doing lately is entertaining as Tonto
and he's likable as the character and
it's not like you'd sit there and go oh
wow I really hate watching Johnny
definitely that's really hard to say I
have a big fan of Johnny Depp and he is
good as the role it's just it feels so
similar to things we've already seen in
the past and it would be great if he
would do something a little more
grounded again I want to see him do
something else like secret window again
or a better movie the nick of time but
that kind of performance like a real
grounded person in reality performance
he's really great with that stuff
The Lone Ranger was entertaining from
time to time but for the most part it
was a constant mess of things that
didn't make sense that felt way to over
long too bloated and too huge and
characters that didn't really mesh very
well and the chemistry wasn't really
snappy like I wanted it to be because
the structure of the movie in the
screenplay just doesn't support these
larger-than-life elements just too much
stuff happening and strangely enough
very boring at times despite all that
stuff happening I'm gonna give the Lone
Ranger a c-minus it could have been
better it could have been a lot better I
think and
it wasn't really the type of movie that
I was expecting it to be so thanks as
always for watching guys if you see the
movie I'd be understood knowing what you
thought of it as well if you liked this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]